we've had a lot of people reach out to
specifically from Canada that are
working professionals like doctors
who've had former patients decide that
they didn't like what they were saying
on Twitter I've had discussions with all
sorts of teachers and nurses and lawyers
and Physicians a good proportion of
these people are so terrified of the
regulatory bodies that there isn't a
hope in hell that they're going to be
able to tell you the truth when you're
in the middle of a medical educational
or legal crisis for 175 years it was
okay in Canada to basically put trust in
the public institutions educational
institutions and professional colleges
and even the political parties you knew
what they stood for and generally they
played the game straight and that's
flipped completely upside down in the
last seven years